encore sans mosquées salafistes qui ne
sont pas fermées on a plus de 4000
étrangers ficher est-ce qu'ils sont
toujours sur le territoire donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait concrètement pour
ces sujets là monsieur darmanin
avant-hier nous dit je vais d'ailleurs
il recycle une annonce qui l'avait fait
deux jours avant l'attentât
je vais expulsé 231 étrangers fiché s
sur 850 irrégulier fichier s et sur 4000
sont étrangers total affiché est ce
qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec les 45000 salafistes qui sont
sur le territoire et qui propagent leurs
idéologies dans carte dans les quartiers
ça c'est un vrai sujet n'est disent
toutes les associations notamment
non mais ils sont pas tous en
association ils sont chez eux ils font
du prosélytisme dans les quartiers dans
les coins de rue et un moment donné sont
suivis par des services de renseignement
et mais je vous dis simplement une chose
et peut-être que on me m'accusera
d'extrémisme sur ce plan-là je crois que
si nous décidions un moment donné de
véritablement nous donner la guerre les
moyens de la guerre contre l'islamisme
il faut avoir le courage d'interdire
certaines philosophies le salafisme en
fait partie pour le moment il est
protégé par la liberté d'expression
est-ce qu'on peut encore protégé par la
liberté d'expression des gens qui
travaillent à nous asservir demain je ne
le crois pas c'est à la république
d'être assez forte pour protéger le
peuple français ça veut dire
interdiction du salafisme
mais une interdiction effective comme
philosophie et doctrines politiques et
sectaires mais vous ne pouvez pas on est
dans un état de droit la baie l'état de
droit n'est pas l'état qui doit laisser
le peuple se faire assassiner
qu'est ce que c'est que l'état de droit
quand il donne des moyens à ses
adversaires pour nous asservir pas ce
langage sur ses têtes l'état de droit et
à saumon l'état de droit c'est l'état
constitutionnel qui protègent les
libertés publiques camp des ennemis à
l'intérieur du territoire français font
tout pour essayer nous asservir et nous
faire taire on n'est plus dans l'état de
droit ils se servent de nos loin pour
nous asservir c'est intolérable
quand je vous dis qu'il faut un moment
donné un état de guerre contre ces gens
c'est précisément parce que la loi
aujourd'hui les protège et nous ne
pouvons pas l'accepter vous êtes cette
question là où vous savez la laïcité
c'est une digue c'est la digue que la
république mais pour faire la séparation
entre l'espace privé et la conscience
plus et et l'espace public donc le voile
donc pour le voile il doit être bannie
au même titre que tout signe religieux
nous signe de religieuses ayant presque
tous les espaces qui représente le
service public
moi j'ai pris une décision en 2015 je me
suis d'ailleurs ou mazel dans la
position devant la loi fillon s'était
dit rien à part supprimant les plats de
substitution dans les cantines
elle a été beaucoup discuté ces
décisions pourquoi elle a été discutée
tout simplement parce que là aussi ont
rétabli un fonctionnement de neutralité
les accompagnatrices scolaires
participent du service public de
l'éducation
elle y participe elles ne peuvent donc
pas arborer un quelconque signe
religieux
vous me parlez du voile en l'occurrence
pas celui ci la faculté c'est pareil
c'est un service public
il ne faut pas admettre le doigt
d'autant que le voile mais que la partie
visible derrière vous avez des
revendications pour des salles qui
peuvent devenir des salles de prières on
connaît ces exemples dans les
universités françaises
donc soyons fermes nous demandons
simplement que de la fermeté on ne veut
pas changer la mentalité des gens mis
leurs croyances mais elle reste à la
porte du service public et la soeur et à
votre